Beto mentioned that we should provide
bitmaps at different resolutions.
In our app, the 48dp icon on the Nexus S
looks to be about the same size
as on the Nexus 4, and on the Nexus 5.
However, in reality, this asset
that's being displayed,
is actually a lot bigger
in terms of pixels
compared to this one.
To confirm, we can check out
the app resource folders.
In the drawable folders, we see that
our app has a 48 x 48 pixel launcher icon
for mdpi devices located
in the drawable mdpi folder.
To make an equivalent icon,
for the higher density devices,
we need to make that icon
progressively larger.
To know exactly how big
to make these images
and what the dp pixel
conversion should be,
we use an mdpi device as the baseline.
This is where one dp equals one pixel.
Then on the HDPI device,
one dp equals 1.5 pixels.
And then it increases from there,
all the way to an XXHDPI device,
where one dp equals four pixels.
For more info on the conversions,
see the link below.
Following those rules, these are
the sizes of the launcher icon
in our drawable folders.
The MDPI one is 48 pixels x 48 pixels.
The one for HDPI is
1.5 times the size of this one.
For an XHDPI device, the icon
is two times the size of the MDPI one,
And for an XXHDPI device, the icon
is three times the size of this one.